we actually just think we should just be
good at relationships we don't even get
a lesson on it I got zero lessons on it
and I went to Catholic school so I
actually started with negative lessons
you know and I was taught that there was
a giant white guy in the cloud with a
beard that would decide if I was a good
guy or a bad guy like it's so stupid and
you don't get to find out till you get
to the gates like how dumb is that so
much of you even of our perception of
self fix is externalized that that God
is outside of you but anyone's who's
experienced love I think it's Alan Watts
who says ask anyone who doesn't believe
in God ask them that when they're having
an orgasm
when we stop running from our challenges
relationally that's where the gold is as
you said I mean I I think the challenge
culturally is that we are taught to
avoid conflict we're not taught the
skills to build Bridges we're not taught
the skills too deep in relationship
we're taught that if someone has an
opposing view or an opposing way of
being that they're just wrong
foreign
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Mark Groves he's a
speaker writer and motivator I've been
following his work for years he talks
about relationships from all
perspectives today I tried to get into
some spaces maybe that he hadn't I
hadn't seen videos on like if you want
to know about gaslighting and if you
want to know about
um you know ghosting and things like
that like he's got videos so we got into
some different stuff we got into some
masculine feminine we got into some
purpose we got into with the role of a
male and a female is we got into and
then like at the end we started started
talking about a stuff that's really just
more Curiosities that he has within
himself and but the funny thing is and
this is why I gotta listen to the whole
thing is that there is no separation
between the work on the self and the
work on anything else and like our world
will change when we change and so we
just talked about all of those
interesting ways and how we can change
within ourselves and ways that we we can
do it and then of course how that may
show up in our world and maybe some of
the areas that that need it most so um I
had a lot of fun with this episode and
of course if you love this podcast
please hit subscribe let me know in the
comments what you want to hear more
about hey nice little Blast from the
Past you get to hang out at home you
know I guess maybe the the happy and sad
thing is that I've spent many many
months here I've had to recover from
many many heartbreaks I've I've just
spent many months here so I like truly
have my own room here and my own stuff
um but I guess it's good that you have
somewhere you can go right totally I
have every time I go back home I'm
always just uh it's it's nice to know
that you have a place to land if you
need it and I've spent a I've spent a
few heart breaks with the parents where
my mom is like do you want a sandwich
what do you need and I'm like I'm not
hungry you know I feel like I'm
miserable guys oh I've been there where
mom's like you have to eat I'm like I
don't deserve to eat
she's like you have to eat something
which is like rare for me I'm one of
those people that can just like no
matter what I'm I don't forget to eat
um yeah yeah heartbreak that's a that's
a [ __ ] those are a [ __ ]
they really are and especially how much
they affect our appetite you know I
think shame pain all that kind of stuff
just makes it so we don't want to eat
and you know we're our gut isn't exactly
at the time being like well maybe
chocolate or ice cream might suit it a
little bit but you know generally we're
just kind of caught in the middle of the
morose nature of it ruminating and
catastrophizing and
trying to make it make sense
I didn't think we'd start at heartbreak
but we're here so why not
what what is it what is it about maybe
we start with attachment like right
because it's just I was I was I've been
having this conversation with my
girlfriends for years about the
difference between being attached in a
friendship and being attached in a
relationship and how you know personally
like I can if a friend does not serve me
or or they're um they suck up your
energy and are full of problems and not
Solutions and
you know just don't have same wavelength
of thinking and living you know I'm
happy to leave that let that go I'm
happy to let that back in too as that
both of those scenarios have happened
um but there's this really challenging
um attachment with relationships where
it just feels
so painful when it's ending or there's
so much abandonment whether it's self or
other throughout it of emotions why is
it that we can't approach a relationship
similarly to a friendship yeah it's
interesting that we don't tend to have
the same level of discernment you know
or even sometimes the same standards
that we would have for a friendship we
don't even have for a romantic
relationships I think there's so much
more going on you know we're not just
attached to the person which can be a
really healthy thing you know it's
healthy to be able to depend on people
and know that when things are going awry
in life that you've got someone you can
lean on I mean that's a part of healthy
relating it's just when your
relationship is something that completes
you that you are then left or
perceptionally left incomplete if it
ends you add to that that we are also
very attached to relational outcomes and
I wouldn't say that's only because
there's something nice about having
stability and knowing what the future
might be you know there's that sort of
quells our anxieties and we can maybe
predict that tomorrow morning will be a
little more reliable or predictable
assuming our relationship will still be
there it's destabilizing and that's why
when people fight one of the worst
things you can do is put the
relationship on the line like if this
doesn't happen I'm leaving if you know
or I'm going right now or this is over
if that's a tactic that we use
relationally there's no there's no
psychological safety and when I say
attached to outcomes we'll think about
what we normally perceive about people
who break up and I met this woman the
other day who in immediately in the
beginning of our conversation she had no
idea what I did for work so it wasn't
anything to do with that she said I'm
getting divorced and I was like oh wow
and she said I know like what a failure
and I was like oh no no what a
Liberation you know I that's that
statement right there just speaks to how
we tend to perceive relationships it's
that if they end we're a failure and if
we get divorced we're seeing and you see
this with relational hierarchy you know
we have a hierarchy to relational status
and what I mean by that is we say if
someone's married they're doing better
than someone who's engaged and someone
who's engaged better in doing someone
who's dating and someone who's dating
better than someone who's single and
then someone who's divorced is sort of
seen as often below that as if there's
something wrong with them because they
have this evidence that a relationship
didn't last and you can see the opposite
of that hierarchy by the questions we
ask when someone is dating when are you
getting engaged when are you getting
married when you're having a kid when
are you having a second one right and so
that alone this idea when someone says
why are you single as if you're
suffering from some sort of ailment that
it can't be by choice you know all of
that produces this expectation or where
our self-worth or our social status is
connected to our relational status and
that I would say is actually the
greatest momentum that creates so much
pain with relational endings because
it's not just that my relationship
ending ended which can actually be an
incredibly healthy thing
it's actually what it means about me and
not truthfully means about me but what
I've been taught it means about me and
you know if you look historically women
were sort of made more in charge or more
of the responsibility on the
relationship lasting was sort of
centered around more and that's why
women tend to have a better relational
barometer you know is it healthy is it
not they tend to be more sensitive to
relational health and their standard for
relational Health tends to be a little
higher
they tend to initiate divorce more than
men
um all that to say like if you look
evolutionarily Harriet Lerner talks
about this she's a psychologist she
talks about how you know like why is it
that women want to learn about
relationships more than men and I think
if you look at anyone's social media
static statistics you'll see that that's
inevitably true and she says it's
because every subordinate group needs to
learn the needs and nuances of the
dominant group to survive so from a
survival based perspective women needed
to learn how to navigate emotion
especially unstable emotion because the
cost literally could be death and so
there's an immense amount of desire to
learn how to dance with emotion how to
understand it and and you think there
this might just be a bias so I recognize
that they tend to be more communal too
like more communal focused
um and again whenever I say men tend to
be this or women tend to be there's
always so much in between too so if
someone's like that's not me it's not
you and that's totally cool we're
generalizing sorry so are you saying
that maybe
um
some of the weight of the attachment in
a relationship versus friendship
comes from
outside perception yeah or are you
saying perception of self
both how outside perception influences
perception of self and the idea that
outside perception should influence
perception of self which is really
evolutionarily you know it's Gabor mate
talks about how we have two needs the
need to belong and the need to
self-express and when self-expression
threatens belonging belonging usually
wins and that's inevitably like I want
to hold the same values the same
perceptions the same beliefs as the
community that I'm in the church I'm in
the and obviously those are all often
synonymous so if I don't hold them then
I might be seen as an other in the group
and I might lose group membership think
about
divorces I mean often religions will
actually Exile a person from their
religion because they've been divorced
and if not literal Exile it will be
communal Exile it'll be everyone will
talk about them and and so all these
things shape when we're attached to a
relationship which you know you think
about romantic relationships are
obviously different than
friendships in that were potentially
creating a family with them we're
potentially sharing a life with them
that's a lot of shared time that's a lot
of shared meals that's a lot of shared
moments and that I mean puts a lot more
weight or we might be more attached
because it is more destabilizing to know
your partner and your relationship might
end
um and I think part of the biological
process of processing heartbreak is the
recognition that a story we thought was
going to happen is no longer happening
and you know when they look at the
research at people's brains they light
up in the same place when they think
about their ex as a cocaine addict so
you know we we kind of become addicted
to them and so part of the physiological
processes of losing a romantic partner
is the story the possibility you know we
don't realize that although the story in
how we envisioned it is changing and the
person we're with is maybe not that
person anymore we can still create that
life and we think it's the death of the
whole future rather than just the how it
looks and and part of the attachment to
how it needs to look is what makes us
hold on and stay static in relationship
and you know one of the things I've
argued for a long time is is because
we're so afraid of relationships ending
we actually oscillate and participated
in the relationship in a way that
reduces the amount of friction in the
relationship because we're afraid this
conversation might end the relationship
not seeing that that's the same
conversation that also would deepen it
we're invited to deepen the idea that
all relationships all are selfish in
nature and self-serving I mean true
because you think we're always getting
something from it and you know even the
self-abandonment is is selfish because
you just want to be with them so it's
really self-serving it's not
you know what I mean like that
everything is to serve the self and what
you think will make you happier or feel
better and that's why survival based
behaviors or mechanisms that we learn
from childhood to self-aband and to
people pleased to even overtly
individuate and become an island that
never gets connection there are all ways
to protect us from being hurt and also
to ensure connection I mean most of us
till we do most of us don't know how do
I hold on to a self and be in
relationship to another person we often
either put at Cost our relationship to
ourselves for the connection to other or
the connection to other uh at the cost
to self so it's either one or the other
we don't tend you know we don't know how
to do both how do I hold on to me and be
in love with you and allow you and me
too you know those are that's hard I
would imagine those are secure secure
attachment as those rare unicorns that
can find the balance and then there's
wherever those people are I don't know
them I've never met one no I'm sure but
um the anxious attached which would be
abandoning the self for the abandoning
yourself or the other person for the
connection and then the then the
avoidant would be are those the sort of
categories that you're applying when you
say that the avoidant would abandon the
relationship for the self yeah exactly
you know in are your listeners familiar
with Detachment Theory and yeah yeah I
mean somewhat I'm I'm sure we get some
new people here and there but I've
definitely broached it many times with
different people but if you want to give
a quick overview I think that's always
great
yeah I mean essentially what you're
saying a secure attachment is the sort
of defining characteristic is my
partner's needs or the other person's
needs matter as much as my own and so
not more than my own which would be more
anxious attachment not less than my own
which would be more avoidant and you
know the
the beautiful thing is no matter what we
might think our attachment style is it
can change so when someone learns it
they often say I'm anxiously attached no
you're just prone to anxious attachment
but if you say I am then you're gonna
stay in it right you can't identify with
the thing so all of us can learn secure
attachment the reason it's based on
Research by Jonathan Balby originally
and they had a mom with a baby and the
mom would leave the room and come back
and then they'd observe how to Baby
interact with Mom when the mom came back
and the baby was like anxious attaches
to Mom it's like ah you know when you
leave I'm not sure you're coming back is
essentially the behavior so as soon as
Mom comes back into the room they don't
leave Mom's side so there's not really a
trust there the second one Mom leaves
mom comes back baby's like hey what's up
reconnects with mom goes back to playing
that's more secure and the last one more
avoidant Mom leaves mom comes back
baby's like didn't even really know you
were gone not a big deal acts as if it's
not affecting them but internally
physiologically they're experience
experiencing the same thing as the
anxious child so you could think about
it like anxious people get triggered by
space in relationship yeah avoiding
people get triggered by a lack of space
so both are experiencing insecure
attachment they're just be they're just
protecting themselves from hurt in
opposite ways exactly right so yeah
you're right though you're dead on like
the avoidance is Will distance from the
relationship to protect self so the cost
is the relationship not the self as
opposed to an anxious person is like
becomes a doormat which kind of points
in the direction of like child work
inner child work I think there's a lot
of people that don't do any of this but
is it essential if you are growing in a
relationship to do inner child work to
understand your patterns to understand
um your attachment style and all that
stuff because it just seems like when
you know it's really part of your life
and I can remember old you know old
times in my life where I had no idea
what any of this was and I just sort of
took everything personally and it was
everybody else's fault but it's not a
lot of Joy either so
oh man that was so mean too like when I
think about being in high school or
university how I was normally more of
anxious secure and then I got really
hurt and betrayed and then I became very
avoidant and you know that's why it's so
easy to oscillate between the two
anxious and avoidant because you're you
don't have to learn security right you
can they're both insecure attachment
Styles so you don't have to become
secure and you know that was when I was
19 so my attachment style dramatically
changed at 19. and that was because
after being experiencing betrayal I made
it mean that when I love people they
betray me and you know here I am you
know not making out on dance floors
while my buddies are some of them are
doing that and talking about it and I'm
like you know no one's in a locker room
being like man monogamy is the best like
my partner and I we had a deeper
conversation then we found another level
of intimacy you know like that's not
often the conversation that's going on
in a locker room
um so you know really very for many more
decades after that right and relational
awareness only can't you know I
originally used to actually be in sales
but also teach sales techniques and all
that kind of stuff and you know when I
went through a breakup I thought to
myself why am I so good at talking about
all these things but not my feelings
like that's not a skill set issue
there's something else going on here and
so that was the beginning of my journey
of wanting to understand romantic
relationships which inevitably if you
begin to understand romantic
relationships your every relationship
will improve you know because it's just
a magnifying glass of the things you
don't do well and I I believe there
might be people who don't believe what
we believe because I totally agree with
you I think
any I think people can create really
fulfilling relationships without any
awareness of why they do what they do
they just happen to be modeled really
healthy relational dynamics that doesn't
tend to be the norm and I would even say
what we're modeled by Disney or romantic
comedies or romantic movies it tends to
be codependency tends to be like
self-abandonment you know like the
woman's laying on the tracks are up in
the tower waiting to save so one is
needing to be saved the other one always
needs to be a night you know it's
there's just so much of that [ __ ]
that goes on in the unconscious and even
our roles that we took on in our
families as kids we often try to take on
in a romantic relationship so
you know I think both people to have
deeply fulfilling relationships need to
have awareness of what their limitations
are and where their skill sets aren't um
because we don't learn this [ __ ] in
school like no you didn't you know like
I started a podcast about it too and I
started writing about because I was like
I gotta learn this stuff like this is
more important than whether I have a
sales award I'd rather have a stable
romantic relationship you know the
interesting thing is you'll likely get
the sales award you know like so that's
the irony it starts at home and there's
so much happiness driven from like your
emotional position of where you're at I
think the real question with that is how
right I think even if someone says oh
yeah I I want to learn about myself or I
I want to do a good job or I want to
know I mean how you know I I mean I've
been you've been doing this longer than
I have for sure but even just in my
experience you have to really be driven
to excavate you have to be driven to dig
into your
um psyche and your patterns and analyze
your family which I'm sure has been
hurtful at times you know like I don't
know I've hurt my family in the process
my parents especially you know and um
um I mean and I always have love and
reverence for them but your your
patterns come from them so like what
does someone do if they are hearing it
and they feel like oh you know I have
these you know I'm not in a relationship
or I'm not happy and you know what what
does someone do to become aware
awareness hard
right I think that ability to have
awareness of your awareness right to be
aware of your patterns to be willing to
ask questions I mean I think the birth
of awareness is asking the question or
the feeling I think there's more to this
you know I feel like I'm tired of this
pattern I'm tired of this feeling you
know it usually that's kind of the crazy
thing about being human maybe it's true
about being a dog too I don't know but
what's crazy about being human is we
tend to wait till we have to change or
we're in some space where it hurts so
much that we have to listen and or do
research in you know you're I think
you're dead on you know you start to
learn about your family and then all of
a sudden you're like my childhood was
effed you know or like this was that and
you you might have anger towards your
parents and I think one thing that
allows us in the exploration and the
excavation of these things is to see our
parents as the children of parents
because then we start to see that you
know they were handed down the same
thing and and you know where do you
begin
for me it's always been following the
breadcrumbs I feel like when you ask the
question much like that saying is uh
when the when the student's ready the
teacher arrives and I think that's true
you know I have had so many incredible
teachers that have no idea they were my
teachers uh a lot of them just from
Reading their books or consuming their
information where I got to learn about
something I was curious about and you
know that that's you know your podcast
is an incredible example of that and
um you know we there's so many resources
available to us it might be someone
today gets this inkling of oh inner
child with the hell is an inner child
you know and then they could literally
just Google that and find out what that
means I think that's a beautiful thing
about where we're at today I think
you're right I think if they're here if
you're here and listening then this is
probably a step you're taking to
understand and it's um feeding that
Curiosity
okay I want to talk about masculine
feminine I want to talk about
roles
um I just I'm only I'm just going to use
myself because that's all I have
he I question all the time like what is
what is a man and a woman like what is
the or a masculine and feminine
relationship I'm just using man and a
woman because that's my situation and
that's your situation in this
conversation but you know there's a
there's definitely usually a masculine
and feminine role and so for just E's
sake of this conversation a man and a
woman so what is that what I'm conf I'm
babbling because I'm so confused about
it but like I'm a woman but I know I'm
more masculine
and
I don't even know if that's something
guys like
you know yeah like I'm so confused like
what am I supposed
I just put some Ruffles on and I was
supposed to like be quiet I don't know
like so anyway I just really Ponder this
sort of dynamic
um a lot and now part of a lot of my
life has been it has been cultivated to
be more to be stronger tougher more
masculine because of the world I lived
in
um also the house that I grew up in the
father you know my dad like the Dynamics
but
um but it's also a lot of it's just me
like I'm just an innately sort of like a
strong sort of direct person so I'm
curious we can use me as an example but
we can sort of go into just all Dynamics
and
um is it is it possible to you know be
is it easy I should should it be easy to
find someone in my position
well first off I'd say the origin story
of you is shattering a lot of those
paradigms you know like you had to
question what it meant and what it meant
about your future in order to even like
you had to shatter those things to
succeed in the way you did so I mean
kudos to you for that because that that
means the melting away of identity had
to occur anyways and even what was
possible for you had to be completely
eradicated because I'm sure people said
that was never possible for you and I
think that's what's fascinating about
generally our own limitations are
actually other people's limitations
there are other people's fears even the
boxes that we believe we have to fit in
relationally you know you think of so
many I mean obviously gender is a big uh
conversation currently about what is
that and how do we explore that but I
think when we even think about it in the
context of what are our roles in
relationship you know there's uh you
know when David data does a lot of the
work in masculine and feminine Jonathan
John Weiland does too and this idea that
in every relationship there is a balance
there is masculine and feminine and it
it
finds balance in itself and so where you
would say you identify more as the
characteristics of the masculine direct
competitive all those things
um I would say that relationally I
probably expressed more feminine I was
competitive and played sports but when
it came to relationships I definitely
was overtly more sensitive more the
feeler more the converse I was the one
who wanted to talk which kind of went
against all the Norms were taught and so
there was an element where I had to
learn to desensitize myself but what I
found in relationship is I often dated I
would say exclusively I dated women who
were competitive athletes and More in
their masculine and I mean what I loved
about that is they were always direct
and great you know very um had high
level of self-confidence maybe due to
sports maybe due to whatever yeah
um but I found that what would happen
and if I think about the shaping of I
grew up in the 80s and 90s and a lot of
the conversation about men which still
exist today obviously is that men are
bad masculine's bad it's race or it's uh
abusive it's you know all these
different things
um and so I Associated boundaries with
actually being controlling and so I
think a lot of my desires was to be a
nice guy like to be different than the
men that women have been taught about my
mom's a feminist and so you know there
was very much like probably a desire to
appease mom in the war work from Robert
Glover who he wrote a book called No
More Mr Nice Guy he talks about how you
know men in their Early Childhood almost
every authority figure like their
teachers Etc are all women so they spend
so much of their youth trying to please
women
and I thought it was just very
interesting right he talks about how
you know so much of like if we don't
stand up to a woman she won't believe
will stand up for her
and I thought that's interesting because
I would say and the reason I say all
this is that if my boundary was tested I
often wouldn't stand in the Integrity of
myself for connection I would people
please I would I would doormat myself in
order to maintain the connection but I
would say is that none of my partners
could really trust me because below my
inability to stand for whatever my
integrity was if I wasn't going to do
that then how could they trust what I
said if I said yes too much right like
you were saying earlier that this
mechanism of people pleasing that offers
a benefit right I get to maintain the
connection but it's at the cost of my
actual self-expression
so all that to say
a long way around the barn to get back
to the conversation about masculine and
feminine I think part of the challenge
that men have who are more feminine who
might Express or identify as more of a
nice guy which is often unintegrated
because it's kindness in order to get
something and that could be true of what
we might say is the unhealthy expression
of feminine and then and I and there's
brought more conversation to that and
the unhealthy expression of masculine
would maybe be the manipulation or
directness or using aggression and
Authority
when a man is more in that sensitized
state and a woman is more in the
directive State and that can be a
healthy High achiever all that kind of
stuff
if the man doesn't know how to stand in
his own truth too and if he does derive
his power from
status from earning from control from
whatever the role he was taught he will
have no idea how to be in relationship
with a powerful woman because there will
be this misconception that he has to
trade something including his
masculinity sure to be in a relationship
with her that both can't be met and
facilitated that are actually deepened
through that experience I hope that
makes sense I yeah not talk through all
those things in one moment I've had guys
tell me they're like you're just so
masculine you're more masculine than me
what is that like what are they saying
I think when one they don't know how to
hold that energy because maybe they
don't know how to express it themselves
like they're not even sure what's in
that there might be even afraid of that
part of themselves that they don't know
how to be in relationship with a
powerful woman and be powerful like they
think there's a trade and also that
there's an association of femininity
with certain things
you know that it has to be softness and
what you said Ruffles you know it has to
be these things as if it can't be
expressed differently I think there's
that's probably a passive way of saying
I'm not sure how to be around that
energy sure okay yeah I mean I mean I
think there's
when when overt individuation because
like a lot of what happened let's say
we're looking at the messaging from the
first ways of feminism and a lot of men
receive the message right like don't be
controlling don't be these things those
are all good things when we're
correcting for behaviors
and a lot of women learned for obvious
reasons don't depend on a man don't need
a man take care of yourself
and those are all important messages too
and a lot of men saw their mothers get
financially abused get left desolated in
divorce and so they again are are
overtly feminizing themselves in that in
response to that they want to protect
they want to do all good those are all
good things but when a child is left to
interpret this information without an
adult explaining it saying yeah it is
important that you are able to take care
of yourself it's important that you're
able to take care of your own needs
but not so that you can't be in
relationship with anyone else like what
ends up happening when it's not
explained is a woman and a man but in
this conversation a woman can learn to
never need anybody
and so that's why overt expression of
the masculine can be this overt
expression of individuation where there
is not actually a surrendering or an
opening if we're using the masculine
feminine language
to actually receive a man or receive
another person and so it's actually
sometimes
uh guardedness masquerading as
masculinity if that makes sense so it's
protective right it's guarded it's
protective yeah and it's a wall yeah and
it's got a fortress around it
and you're just driving what I've talked
about for myself
well that's why sometimes what a man
doesn't know how to use or another
person just doesn't know how to use
language for is you're in your masculine
and what they really might be feeling is
I don't feel like you're open yeah I
don't feel like there's reception to
love Yeah Are there specific roles like
that
um two people coming together I mean
especially if we're looking at masculine
feminine are there you know I've
listened to lots of videos and like got
you know man's looking for somewhere to
like you know not be bothered it should
be easy it should like there's like
videos like that and then you know I
don't really look at the women's side
because I'm a woman so you you know I
feel like I'm just thinking about it
from my perspective but a woman
generally is looking to feel safe she's
looking to feel appreciated she's
looking to feel valued Irreplaceable
um special uh so are there what what are
some like a few on each side
um core
core needs
that each has I'd say at a baseline all
relationships and this is what
attachment does attachment is a radar
and it's constantly going in all our
relationships to say am I safe am I safe
to be me and I'd say at the Baseline of
all relationships romantic too
regardless of your gender is am I
psychologically safe am I safe to
express and be myself now most of us
have messaging from our childhood that
says that's not true so we might project
that in our our relationships there
might be safety present we might not be
attracted to safety because all our
nervous system knows is chaos so is
there certain things that a man needs
versus I think there's so much
complexity to it because like I think of
how many men I know and they all have
different types of like maybe specific
needs that they have so the first I'd
say is psychological safety everyone
needs second one is I think that
men as a collective like one of the
things that I would say we generally are
challenged with that I think most people
would agree with that most women would
agree with is we're pretty challenged
with conversation we're challenged with
emotional conversation and if you think
about it since our birth we've been
socialized to not have emotional
conversation and to also not be attuned
to our emotions and so we might have a
couple acceptable emotions like
aggression especially in sports and
maybe moderate excitement yeah but we're
not in sexual excitement but we're not
allowed generally to have grief and
we're not allowed to have sadness and
any of those things tend to be in
conflict with masculinity and to equate
to weakness so
I think we probably although we might
not know we need it uh and who am I to I
speak for all men I don't but I do think
that we need some patience as we desire
to learn emotional language and to learn
how to communicate whatever age a man is
is that many years less that he's been
exposed to the possibility of emotional
so it's like a totally new language I
remember when I was first trying to have
conversations I was good at sales but as
soon as it came to a conversation with
my partner it was like I couldn't find
words and I would get so flooded and I
didn't know how to have the how to put
words to feelings and that's an art and
yeah I think no matter a person's gender
they can relate to that probably
um and for women I mean I I believe that
they want a man who is deeply rooted in
his Integrity that they can trust his
word
and that they will at least be validated
and being heard you know I think one of
the misconceptions we have relationally
is that we have to agree with each other
and that is some sort of uh sign of
relational success but I actually think
it's more can two truths exist because
we you and I can experience one
situation very differently and that is
probably because it's encoded in our
programming our childhoods our
experiences in life and both of them are
true and the job of a relationship is to
actually unify those things to allow
understanding for both and you know what
is seemingly Beyond two opposing views
is usually a deeper truth and and it's
usually wiser than the first two to
begin with
I'm thinking about a ramdas quote I'm
pretty sure it's ramdas
something along the lines of like the
best thing that I can do for you is to
work on myself and the best thing you
can do for me is to work on yourself
something to that effect I love ramdas
yeah I know so good um we're all just
walking each other home oh so good it's
so good it's so true
um so this is kind of a simple broad
question but I think a lot about the
nature of reality and the purpose of
everything and
energy and frequency and what's all
happening and I wonder
what the point of relationships are
um well I think that ramdas quote is so
apropos that we're all just walking each
other home
you know I personally believe that the
purpose of relationship is you know I I
think love
just might matter enough to us that
we're willing to look at our stuff
there's not a lot of other things that
matter to us enough and if you look at
the deepest core human motivations is
connection and love and
I believe that it it is the purpose and
The evolutionary purpose and I mean
maybe from from both the Consciousness
perspective and uh personal Evolution
perspective
is that relationships they are a mirror
to the things that we're not good at
they show us where we're not free they
show us where we wear masks they show us
our potential like you think about
everything that triggers you is really
an invitation to learn Mastery and the
thing you're triggered about because the
trigger itself is this hypersensitivity
to likely a pre a previous wounding that
just hasn't been processed exactly right
so like when the trigger comes forth we
vehemently protect against experiencing
what we're afraid is going to occur and
that's brilliant intelligence but what
lives in the actual trigger is the
information of what skill would I need
to learn to at least mitigate the
possibility of this happening again and
I think
it really when we can learn how to
manage conflicts successfully when we
can see that it deepens intimacy of self
and other
that we actually can see that conflict
serves us you know it shows me like why
can we not navigate a conversation and
actually end up more in love this is
like Cantonese for most I'm sure right
like think about it would be for younger
me yeah younger me and that's why I'm
saying like
to think that the conflict is the gold
in the triggering is the gold and is
where you can mine to use gold yourself
and figure things out and expose those
shadows and expose those
patterns that aren't serving you and in
areas where you're not free this is a
this is like a foreign concept
it totally is you know especially except
for the people who speak Cantonese then
it's a natural you know concept and in
that there are people that navigate this
language and I think it's a massive
revolution of relationship you know
ultimately like you look at what we tend
to have inherited relationally is
codependency and you know like if you
look up your family yeah wait you're at
home uh if you look up your family and
it's me same and you know if you look up
your family tree and really where we
learn about relationships is from our
families and our societies and our
cultures and our movies
if you never learned how to have
conflict and turn it into deeper
intimacy how the hell would you know how
the skill set is not shared but it can
be learned and Eric Fromm who wrote the
book The Art of Loving he has a great
quote in it where he says that there's
nothing that we fail at more than love
yet don't take the time to learn and
there's sort of this arrogance I think
to Being Human Till It's Gone that we
actually just think we should just be
good at relationships like we have this
narrative that you get married by a
certain age and you're just supposed to
Make It Last Forever like yeah
and you know people can get a lesson on
it I got zero lessons on it and I went
to Catholic school so I actually started
with negative lessons you know and I was
taught that there was a giant white guy
in the cloud with a beard that would
decide if I was a good guy or a bad guy
like it's so stupid and you don't get to
find out till you get to the gates like
how dumb is that you know and so you see
like how much
so much of you even of our perception of
suffix is externalized that that God is
outside of you that but anyone's who's
experienced love and I forget who I
think it's Alan Watts who says ask
anyone who doesn't believe in God
um ask them that when they're having an
orgasm
you know I think there's this
there is a willingness when we've
experienced enough friction relationally
to explore the friction
and when we stop running from our
challenges relationally
and actually realize that you don't have
to run towards them because that's
definitely going to be awkward
especially after you've been running
from them
but when you start to actually just slow
down and turn around and turn towards
them and realize you know that
that's where the gold is as you said I
mean I I think the challenge culturally
is that we are taught to avoid conflict
we are taught to vehemently disagree and
just name call the other side
we're not taught the skills to build
Bridges we're not taught the skills too
deep in relationship we're taught that
if someone has an opposing view or an
opposing way of being that they're just
wrong
and like this is perpetuated our culture
and this has perpetuated our
relationships and you know I think we're
definitely seeing that especially now
relationally and you know really I think
the future for relationship but also
culturally is we all have to become
Bridge Builders we all have to become
the people who say hey actually there's
another way and the other way is about
because you if you return to developing
a more sacred relationship with yourself
which is inevitably what's going to
happen you know I it's Richard Rohr who
says that the journey to finding the
true self is the same as the journey to
finding God
and I love that because if you go to
find God you find self if you go to find
self you find God and you know kind of
speaking to what I said earlier the idea
that there's a differentiation between
those things is I think what is
weaponized against us sometimes but
that's a whole other conversation but in
this return of your relationship to
treating yourself as sacred
is then inevitably
that you will accept nothing less than
sacred and also what you'll share with
your partner is sacred and then the
reverence that you'll have to your
partnership will be so different but
inevitably if you do that you will
return to a sacred relationship to the
Earth and to everything
a mirror both ways right it's it's
you're the mirror to seeing how you need
to change is what you then project you
know
and and the solution you know I speaking
to the things that we are taught to
avoid I mean we're we're taught that
sadness or grief or anger that there's
something wrong with us if we have those
emotions as opposed to
well what happens instead of looking at
it is there something wrong with you and
you said what's right with me that I
feel this way
how can I be informed by that what's it
asking me to change you know I think
that is also this idea that
there's nothing to be found in the
darkness or there's something wrong with
the darkness I mean I've been through
a breakup that brought me to my knees
and
I navigated that breakup sober the first
time I ever navigated a breakup sober
and I felt things that I had never
allowed myself to feel but I'm so heavy
the richest Transformations for me have
always occurred in those sort of like
roots to the ground demand to be felt
spaces like Burn It To The Ground right
no other choice it has right Alchemy
it's just Alchemy right like it's like
becomes
ashes that fertilize the soil for
something else to come through I agree I
think that's one of the hardest things
about
lessons and really especially
relationships is where it comes up the
most but family too not necessarily
romantic
um is that you really have to go through
the [ __ ] like you have to go through
at Burning to the ground process which I
was I from my my my experience is I'm
like if it hasn't brought you to your
knees like you said then it's
you know the the deeper you go into that
sadness and that
depression and the
um self-reflection
um
the the bigger the shift will be and
that sucks why does it have to be like
that it does you know it's the irony too
is that uh that is actually what
enriches love you know like when you
realize that when you love somebody
you are constantly saying yes to losing
them right like you're saying yes the
more you love someone the more you are
actually increasing your capacity for
loss you're actually as you love someone
feeling the grief of losing them and you
know because inevitably you're gonna die
or I'm gonna die or we're both gonna die
but either way the relationship's gonna
end and when we can confront that
and realize that actually in The
Grieving of that is the experience of it
like when I look at my fiance and I
experience the the recognition that
I'm gonna die or she is this
relationship will end this experience
will end then I'm actually able to taste
everything in the moment but the denial
of the death death of self-death of the
relationship is to actually deny the
richness of the present
totally so what an imitation grief is
because grief doesn't give you a choice
and when you can see that grief is
there's a saying that grief is love that
has nowhere to go
um no yeah
and I don't know that it's meant to go
anywhere because I think of like some of
the most painful breakups I've ever had
or painful losses I've ever had
like they are just made richer although
it's hard to process them
uh I don't know I think that's probably
the closest I've ever gotten to whatever
might be the experience of God how do
you differentiate in a relationship the
difference between
the stories you make up in your head and
you know the crazy talk you give
yourself and real intuition
hmm you have to get to know yourself you
know there's my friend Dr Alexander
Salman says a great question to ask
oneself is is this my trauma or my truth
and there's a vibration or an energetic
to trauma and reactivity that's
different than truth and that can be
hard to differentiate I think somatic
work is really important I think like
seeing a somatic therapist learning
about your nervous system learning
because that's really what destabilizes
US is when if we've spent our lives
being vigilant we spent our lives being
protective spent our lives being guarded
spent our lives with unreliable people
that we can't trust then that's
familiarity and then what is uncertain
and unknown is actually stability and so
we might reject that
and the only way to really know how to
differentiate is to get to know yourself
and that's why that I think it's um
the book uh When Things Fall Apart by uh
Pima children she talks about this
principle from Buddhism called my tree
and this principle the idea of it is
that everyone needs to become best
friends with themselves like as opposed
to this you know self-love and it's like
bubble baths and chocolate and all these
things which are all great and
boundaries those are definitely part of
self-love she's saying like actually
develop a reverence for yourself
and when you do that and I said this
before when you develop a sacred
relationship with yourself then you are
able to be Discerning about what because
you already know the sacred
and that takes a deep commitment to
practices like meditation like exercise
like eating well yeah what do you do I
mean like this right like a new
territory for people what is a what is a
practice of knowing the self look like
well what a great first question to ask
is like who am I I mean isn't that sort
of every philosopher's circular uh point
of inquiry you know I'm sure it started
the same for you uh and it started the
same for me and the first book I ever
read after my when I was 27 the
relationship that ended that sort of
made me start to ask questions like how
did I get here why do I do what I do
I feel like there's more to life the
first book I ever read was Man's Search
for meaning by Victor Frankl hmm and
that was the first time I ever even
thought like oh I might have a purpose I
might be here wait there's like uh it's
a miracle to even be born like most of
us don't even recognize that so the
journey to self can begin with what you
resonate with learning about as you were
talked about quantum physics frequency
learn about if you're drawn to books
about Jesus if you're drawn to it
doesn't really matter what the journey
is you know it's I think it's practices
though that are self-reflective things
like meditation that was for sure
beginning Journey for me the breath work
was not big when I first started but I'd
say breath work is
geez that brings you right to the edge
um and cold plunging I don't know coal
plunging is one of the greatest
practices I've ever done I really I
invested in a coal plunge the company is
called the coal plunge and I have it at
45 degrees and I do three to four
minutes three to four times a week and
it started with cold showers and
I don't know your experience of it but
what I found is that I was I was able to
differentiate between my body saying
you're gonna die and freeze to death
from the reality that I wasn't and so I
was able to be the Observer of that fear
and that just increased my skills
relationally when I'm in dialogue with
someone else to be like Oh I'm not
actual like this person isn't actually
rejecting me we are disagreeing and that
doesn't mean my future and my
relationships and my well-being are on
the line I was able to start exploring
thoughts like that from more of an
observational rather than reactive state
I'm curious what are some of the things
that you did that begin the journey to
getting to know self I think you nailed
it with just like just being curious and
seeing a pattern and wanting to my first
question was what is God
that was true that was my first that
lead you
well everyone answers
with like oh well he makes decisions and
it's uh you know this whole powerful
being exactly is it he I was having so
many of these conversations we we've
touched on here I've been having with my
mom because again I'm home and I was
trying to explain the difference between
spirituality and religion and my mom and
I was asking if she had gone to church
as much and she since covet I think that
kind of shifted a lot of things and then
I was like well I can start sending you
spirituality videos if you want she's
like well what is like what is
spirituality so I think it's this quest
to understand
why we're here what we are what's really
happening I mean have you had mystical
experiences or
transcendental experiences out of body
astral projecting medicine Journeys have
you have you had experiences that show
you a different reality
yeah you know when I was
I want to say like 19 or 20 I did
mushrooms for the first time but it was
more in a
it was camping and it wasn't with any
medicinal intent you know it wasn't I
wasn't doing much yeah I wasn't doing
much with consciousness
but since I've done them with intent
oh yeah there's a study actually that
looks at people using mushrooms that
shows that people who have committed
crimes who use them re-commit crimes at
a far lesser rate than people who have
never had a mushroom experience and they
pay uh some credit to the possibility
that it's because when you take
psychedelics you experience a sense of
connectedness of Oneness
um so there's that I mean
yeah I mean I've had experiences where
voices have said stuff to me that I
needed to hear in the moment or
clarifying things you know one when I
was going through that more recent
breakup that I was saying really
deepened everything for me it deepened
my relationship to everything and I was
sitting beside a river right after
and I saw I mean I saw a bald eagle fly
right in front of me along the river
which was wild like right in front of me
and then I saw this white butterfly
flying and I just thought like that
butterfly doesn't really think about
what it does it doesn't like it's just
going somewhere I don't it's going to
eat something or die or I don't know
what it was going to do mate who knows
and and I thought isn't it so
fascinating that like we
we question everything and we actually
question the purpose or Mission that on
summer level we're constantly being
invited to you know our voices our
intuition all these voices that we learn
to quell or to take drugs to minimize or
get you know I think a lot of our
addictions are sourced from the
avoidance of the pain of knowing there's
a better version of us available a
different version of potentiality that
we haven't touched and because it's so
normalized to not touch that
potentiality it's actually normal to be
in a state of addiction to avoid that
voice and you know I think there's
definitely a mess Awakening to that now
um but I really thought to myself I
remember I just heard these words like
at what point did you think you were God
because I was trying to force a
relationship that didn't want to be born
okay okay and I was just like oh that's
a call out that's a call out you know
like why did I lose trust why did I stop
believing in that the it life is just
trying to flow through me and it's us
who get in the way of that and I think
so much of the work that relationship
offers is to
show where our conditioning is keeping
our behaviors the same keeping our
relationships it's normal to be in a
disconnected lifelong relationship yeah
isn't that [ __ ] like it's normal and
it's so normal I was just chatting with
my dad two hours ago and just talking
about relationship stuff and
and he's like you know most people are
not happy you know because I made some
joke about being 40 and single and he's
like yeah but most most people are
really happy
what kind of stuff are you questioning
now are there what's on your search and
explore list right now
oh man you know and it could it could
have to do with relationships fine of
course I know that's a passion and an
interest but might not be oh no it's
gone so much beyond that yeah but you
know I think relationship sort of
touches on everything that it's right
but there's only so far to go because
there's only so much patterning and
there's only so much exactly like
actually it starts off as almost
confusing and then you kind of Whittle
it down and you're like oh it's just
kind of like this like I just look at it
now I'm just going
I know I get what vibrationally I'm
putting out there and I get what I
expect I deserve and um the world is a
mirror for me and like it gets kind of
distilled down to some simple things so
okay then let's let's talk about fun
stuff outside of that then what's what's
a curiosity
well you know I think so much of my I
think all generally a lot of our work is
derived from our own desire to want to
understand the world you know that I
turned my mess into my message but I
constantly have a mess so you know I've
I feel like I really worked on healing
codependency individually in my own
personal life and looking at how do I
create a relationship that is liberating
that instead of being a prison where
we're not allowed to leave or we're
stuck we got married or in relationship
and we we have to stay the same people
that enter relationship as opposed to
the relationship being the place that
says there's more for both of you in the
relationship has to keep getting the
container of the relationship has to
expand to accommodate our expansion
individually and collectively so is
there a fundamental truth or a
fundamental piece of information that
helped you liberate that aspect of
yourself out of codependency
yeah I mean the recognition that my
partner out of however many billion
people are on the planet chooses me and
she could choose not to choose me you
know and the recognition of the truth
that she could leave in any moment
but chooses to stay made it so I think
one of the things that we most often do
in relationship is we assume that
choosing one another today means that
you can't go anywhere and marriage
especially it's like till death do us
part was a common vow and I always
thought to myself like which death like
a mortal death or the death of the self
that shows the relationship at the time
and we don't tend to have the skill sets
to be able to experience the mortality
of the old parts of ourselves that will
occur throughout our lives if we let
that happen which just means that we're
growing and expanding and becoming
better people and more skills and and
all the things and relationships have
not generally been structured on the
celebration of both being an individual
and being together like there's this
fear that if you grow you'll grow out of
the relationship and so I'm gonna do
everything I can to try to keep you here
as opposed to the more you grow the more
I grow the more we grow and if we're not
attached to it having to be us
but that's our desire
right if we're not attached to it then
we allow the free flow of the
relationship to go so letting go and
that's just hard yeah I'm saying it's
great in theory you know yeah no but
seriously though that has been the
acknowledgment of the recognition that I
never
want my partner to ever have to abandon
herself to choose us
like I don't want that I would never
want that for her in the moment she ever
believes that is what is required then
we are of art we're already losing and
so can we bring even those fears or when
that's coming forward to the table and
can the relationship hold the truth that
already exists as opposed to avoiding
the truth so that we can try to stay
together you know like we broke up and
spent a year apart not expecting to get
back together and then came back
together and came back together as two
different people came back together
um more complete the actual leaving of
the relationship was necessary because
it was the saying we're in service of
love not the need to be together yeah
and and we got to experience a
relationship ending with Grace I mean I
didn't even know you could do that you
know I didn't know you know I
interviewed this woman on my podcast
she's a chef her name's Yoda which what
a great name for delivering wisdom and
she said uh that she got the advice once
that you should leave a relationship as
you leave a house
like fix it up for the next owner and I
thought what a beautiful concept that
yeah that actually to be in service of
love is to leave sometimes you know that
that's taking all my [ __ ] before and
I've left a lot of [ __ ] so I'm not
really sure what my pattern is but
well don't we all you know but it's it's
like kin
like when we our relationship ended we
did a closing ceremony yeah it's amazing
I'd never done anything like that we lit
a fire I looked up closing ceremony
relationships some other people had
thought about this before they probably
lived in Encinitas or Sedona and I uh
and I with that book what is it uh
conscious uncoupling I think that was
the beginning of I forget which
relationship the Gwyneth Paltrow yeah
um Catherine Woodward Thomas I think is
the author something like that
um but we did that and that was one of
the hardest things I've ever done in my
life but it was one of the most
deepening because we just spent the time
thanking each other and having gratitude
um so with all that said yeah the
evolution of
healing individual codependency to
looking at Collective codependency I'm
very fascinated by cultural patterns
that are occurring right now which is
that
you know we have created these camps no
matter what the belief is that it's
you're either this or you're that you're
there's no conversation anymore and
we've canceled dialogue we've actually
in a lot of ways I think that our world
has continued to accommodate and
oscillate around the people who have the
lowest capacity for discourse and the
most emotional reactivity
and because of that because we've sort
of like allowed that experience to
dictate what we can talk about and what
subjects are okay to talk about
well as soon as we stop dialoguing about
any subject we stop deepening our
understanding of it you know and and for
the if we make all of our dialogues
oscillate around the fear that we don't
want to hurt someone's feelings then we
will never have progress
you know because you and I as I said
earlier experiencing a situation
differently
the goal of and success of navigating
that is not agreeing it's that we
actually both can co-exist and find some
deeper truth that lives beyond our own
individual one it's kind of like
politically there's the left there's the
right there's the blue there's the red
there's the pro there's the ante there's
but the truth exists so much in between
all of those things yeah you know and
and so I'm my questioning goes to
why where does that come from how do we
resolve it and
it
I think that if you we stop having
conversations that are cancelable
then we are participating in the
cancellation of that subject and and
it's so easy to do that because really
what continues to be weaponized against
people is belonging
that if you don't agree you don't belong
and I'm gonna like I believe I agree
with accountability culture
um but I'm I also am in total uh
supportive restorative justice not
cancel culture you know and because
cancel culture has permeated itself
through everything it's made it so
people are self-censoring they're not
sharing their truth they're not sharing
what's real for them because they're
afraid they won't belong anymore and
what happens is we have the illusion of
consensus so everyone pays the price and
so that has been a real because I think
of what is the costume relationship for
that well we have a bunch of people in
relationship together who are just
appeasing each other and I personally
don't want to participate in that type
of family that type of culture I want to
have hard conversations because I know
that they are imperative to
to just human progress
so is this fixable on the outside
meaning is there some sort of
let me just say it more simply do you
think that this is an inside job to be
solved meaning it's all within
individuals to fix the self in relation
to a partner to the planet to others to
dis people that are different or that
disagree is it an inside job that
actually fixes the outside or is there
actually something that can be done
because I think that's the problem is I
think that people think that they can
kind of scream from The Mountaintop
something or hold a sign up and like it
will change everything but that's kind
of on the outside going in like you're
trying to impress something upon
somebody and there might you know
there's arguably some benefit to it but
the truth may lie in the inside job
yeah I what a great question
when
when we have uncertainties around our
own position and I think religion really
speaks to this as an example
part of faith is not questioning and so
in doing that you're already teaching
people not to question and so how that
permeates our schools and our academic
institutions and just our authoritative
structure is political media all the
things is that
especially I think recently we're not
allowed to question anything and if you
question things then you're seen as
being selfish or being in the way of
some form of progress
and as where the perception is is that
opposition is actually halting progress
I think what we really need to look at
is that all of us have
conflicting thoughts within ourselves
beliefs have become so
uh intermixed with our identities that
challenging our beliefs is challenging
psychologically our identities and so we
haven't allowed a fluidity to our own
ability to take in information and in a
lot of ways we've added we've abandoned
humility that's required to say Maybe
I'm Wrong maybe your perspective
actually will inform my perspective but
when I see that your perspective might
eradicate or change mine based on valid
truths based on a valid information
if my identity is associated with that
belief I will do anything to guard it
exactly and
and so I do think it's an inside job I
think it's the recognition of our own
biases the recognition of where we
um have beliefs like I have a friend
named Louis solaro who says that we
should live as if one of the five core
pillars that we base our identity upon
we should always live as if one of them
is dead wrong and it's usually the one
that we cling to most
and I've always loved that because I've
realized like I'm prone to also wanting
to be right and you know I'm quite
outspoken and I've had to learn in the
last two years as I've explored this
subject
how to build a bridge how to
if someone tries to put me in a left or
a right or a blue or a red or a pro or
an ant then I'm like none of those
labels apply to me like I'm not going to
participate in that anymore I don't
actually want to unders and curiosity is
really the solution because there's
times when someone has a deferring
opinion to me that I don't want to know
more about their opinion but I know I
know that that's actually the path of
progress I've thought about this myself
a lot and how it feels to me like people
that are really not open-minded and not
welcoming of other thoughts is
especially when it's based on the the
foundational stuff like religion or
politics or family or core beliefs or
whatever how you grew up is that there
is like a subconscious awareness that
it's the house of cards that will fall
once one of those comes one one of those
foundational elements now you believe
isn't true anymore it sort of
subconsciously implies that what else is
wrong you know everything like isn't
that because the moment you even start
questioning things relationally and what
you're were taught about relationship it
is the gateway to recognition that you
were taught everything generally
everything and most of what we're taught
is [ __ ] in when when that was my
Gateway I mean I was a pharmaceutical
rep so talk about breaking down my house
of cards it was like slinging Viagra
left and right you know I never sold
Viagra but I sold pretty much everything
else and I worked in the hydrocodone
left and right
I sold a lot of different things but
when I started to study relationships
and emotion I started to see that so
much of inflammation was due to
emotional dysregulation and high
conflict relationships and I thought oh
my god I've been selling and promoting
and developing these disease States
that I'm not saying they don't exist
right what I am saying though is that I
was selling things that were to treat
essential States and symptoms that are
actually Associated usually with trauma
usually with dysregulation usually with
emotional suppression yeah and I start
to see so much of right like we're not
talking about the core things in
I mean having worked in that industry
and then studied psychology and human
behavior it just made the last two years
of my life be like I can't not see what
I see now and right
um what did it I mean like the last
couple of years having that kind of
contrast like what what what was your
what was your
opinion and and and observation of the
last couple
well you know originally
you know I was probably like a lot of
people I looked at what was coming in
the news I saw people falling on their
faces and I'm like this shit's gonna get
real like I don't want to get whatever
is this magic fainting disease
um
and then as I saw it sort of permeate
through or or move through society and I
started to read the studies because I
had been trained to look at that kind of
stuff and I was making my own risk
assessment and looking at it and I was
reading the studies and I'm like hmm
like this doesn't make sense that that
we're sort of this absolutist about
everything like this is interesting how
the the messaging is changing and
I used to sell a product actually that
used the test that they used PCR test
and so that was a red flag for me
because I knew that you could use it for
Diagnostic purposes I knew how the test
worked so that was a red flag for me and
then when I saw the way the clinical
trials were being set up and the claims
they were making based on the clinical
trials that was a red flag for me and
I'd say the greatest red flag was how I
saw Public Health begin to moralize
behavior and use language like I was
watching them say they did the right
thing
um you know saying that getting the the
V I don't even want to use the word
because I know it Flags everything which
how big of a red flag is it that you
can't even use a word anymore right
um
but what I saw was I'm from Canada so a
lot of the language was that I saw was
very much like
Canadians did the right thing they did
this they did this and I just started to
see like you're a selfish person if you
don't if you don't lock down you don't
but I also saw the research on lockdowns
and I'm like well this is a red flag
there's no research to show that these
work but yet we're gonna
I can understand two weeks let's sure
but as soon as it kept going and then
the total gaslighting of anyone who had
any medical person who had an
oppositional view who had credentials
but no longer was credentials the source
of status it was actually agreeing any
questioning I had about taking it myself
which I'm not against any of it someone
could I don't care what people choose
I was instantly called auntie and that
was I was like wait I'm not Auntie like
can I anyone who had a side effect was
gaslit and denied all these things
together were just I was just like what
the [ __ ] is happening and
you know I'd look at it
I don't it's a mess like to me it's a
mess because I've just watched this
psychological manipulation that's been
occurring through language in in
moralization
and uh it's really made me very curious
to understand that human behavior on
such a deeper level and probably more so
to just understand how you know you can
exist
in relationships with people who
have totally different views and still
love them I think that's so important
and I didn't feel like that was true
so what's kind of the macro of this like
if I mean I'm guessing that you probably
might look at this from a more macro
perspective like what's happening with
the planet with humans with
Consciousness like do you have an
opinion of like of the
of the the the the the are we in some
kind of alchemy on our way to something
you know I I I think it's easy to fall
into sort of the gloom and doom uh
especially if we're consuming media you
know I think one of the important things
that we need to really take
responsibility for is the information
that we're consuming you know we forget
that platforms like social media are and
media in general are literally designed
to keep your attention so they're
designed to enrage you they actually
monetize your attention so their best
interest is not your mental health their
best interest is your attention and
however they get to keep you is
emotionality it's really emotional
extremes are you enraged and are you are
you following information that agrees
with your perspective and
so I mean I think from an optimistic
perspective I think that what is true of
nature always is something greater is
being formed you know I think that
systems that have been held together and
motivated by profit are to a lot of
people it's becoming pretty obvious that
those motivations are
being a priority and we've done this
with the planet and we've done this you
know where we just keep extracting from
the planet and we don't consider the
long-term outcomes and it's all for more
more and more and more and it's like
when will we get back into harmonious
relationship with the planet and we
extract but we don't restore and I think
it's indicative of how we do
relationship and so you know much like
you said it it all starts with the self
and then when you change your own
behaviors
you instantly change every single
relationship you're in and then all
those relationships are invited to
deepen and change or not and
I have been challenged in the last two
years where I have felt and I'm not
saying this as a victim but rather an
observation of my experience is that
I have felt like
my perspective was seen as wrong or bad
or people couldn't love me because I
didn't want to choose to get a medical
intervention and I thought that's so
interesting like
but what it's really taught me is that
I also started to other the people I
felt othered by
and so I started to create the same
divisiveness that I was feeling hurt by
and so I had to do healing to say you
know there's a quote that says um if you
draw a circle to exclude me I'll draw a
bigger Circle to include you
and that has been really sort of a
foundational
intention in my days to say I forget
where it comes from the saying but it
before you say anything or do anything
or create anything to ask yourself is it
useful and is it kind and I think I only
asked is it useful and I think a lot of
the ways where I wanted people to
understand the pain I was feeling
um some of the like memes I share or
something weren't necessarily always
kind they were like you know notice my
pain and no progress is uh held by using
the same energy that the pain was
created in
amen
I think that's so true I think you just
gave us a lot of really good advice and
I think that uh you know
this sort of parallel between you and
the self you and the you and family you
and relationship you and the planet you
and people that you don't agree with you
and other institutions and
um you know it starts with the self and
then it just
spirals into all the others and let's
hope that we're in this beautiful
new spiral from where we were into a
more open
space where we can hear each other
I love that you know I think one thing
that I've learned in the last couple
years especially is that
pretty much everybody is operating from
a space of love and how we protect
ourselves from hurt and even the
strategies that we use to try to get
love are not always healthy
um but that's usually the intention and
so when we can start to see that as the
intention then we don't villainize the
other but rather start to have
compassion
and you know the compassion for what
they're doing or their thoughts or
beliefs actually has compassion for ours
especially the ones that you know we
have difficult or challenging parts of
ourselves that we have to have
compassion for and we have to be willing
to excavate so
you know something deeper is being born
how do you feel about it so I've used
this example of cymatics of
patterns from frequencies emerging from
Sand or whatever they you know water any
any kind of soft substance and the
pattern will have to go into disarray
and complete
a completely a complete mess before it
can shift and transition to the next
higher octave or frequency or more
complicated pattern and that we're in
that transition right now and
it's almost like you have to kind of
pull apart and before things can kind of
go back or find their find their
homeostasis again it's like kids testing
a boundary you know to see where they
can see where it actually should land
um I think that there's a lot of
boundaries being tested right now that
we're in this sort of dismantling of of
the pattern and we will re-emerge at a
higher frequency with a more complicated
pattern that will serve us all so much
better
period so agreed and so our work
individually is to move ourselves to
that higher frequency contribute to that
pattern
with yourself
and honoring the Integrity of why we
came here and what our own potential is
you know because
so many of us don't honor the call we
don't want to listen we ask for a
message from God not that one though you
know we it's not that not that you know
and it's getting into Integrity with our
potential that's everything
yeah well thank you very much this is a
beautiful conversation
to the Beauty and the pain of alchemy
yeah the cooking the cooking yeah thank
you so much for having me thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button